what do you think about how zelinski is
handling everything
he's been brilliant
i mean i mean
zielinski was an actor
who
played the role of president on a
popular television program and people
would joke to him to say you ought to be
run for president you know these all
these other guys are doing a terrible
job
and he did and he won and
i never expected this out of him but
he's risen to the moment he understands
his symbolic importance to democracy to
ukraine and he's been brilliant and uh
and
you ever met him uh once but not in an
important way i mean yeah and
and like ronald reagan and really like
donald trump he understood how you use
the media to promote
and and what he's doing
you know one of the criticisms i always
had about the west is their
sort of
superficial support for ukraine being a
part of europe there's a lot of history
as to why they didn't want ukraine to be
a part of europe but they could never
say that
um
and you look at the support that the
eastern europe east western europe was
giving to ukraine until it became
unconscionable not to give it lethal aid
and uh and you see exactly what i'm
talking about
excuse me
but what zielinski has done
is he recognizes the the sort of
duplicity of the leadership of europe
and so he's speaking to these
legislatures the brilliant part of that
move is not that he's speaking to the
politicians he's speaking to the people
in those countries that those
legislators represent and he's forcing
those legislatures
to actually give him the lethal aid that
he needs
because he's creating the political you
know groundswell in their countries
that's his brilliance and he's also
calling on artists to create
the groundswell that you're talking
about
because he understands
that the european political community
and the washington political community
by the way
is is not
there were a lot of reasons why they
were comfortable with the sort of data
that existed between
russia and ukraine
you know with ukraine being western
oriented a democracy not under russian
control but not outside of russian
hegemony they they accepted that merkel
you know who i think was a terrible
leader for the for western democracies
uh you know she was she was a patsy for
putin you think merkel was a terrible
leader and a patsy for putin how do you
say that because i think that she
basically empowered putin to do what
putin is doing today
with north stream too yeah which totally
undercut ukraine i mean the life
economic lifeblood of ukraine was that
pipeline and because it flows from
russia through ukraine
all european gas went through there
um and
she understood the importance of it
but she signed the north stream two deal
which was going to choke off
ukraine
create a vassal state that's what putin
was trying to do was one have the
europeans dependent on the pipeline that
he controlled and two
kill ukrainian at the same time
by taking it away i mean putin has been
playing these moves for a long time the
west they're not stupid they've
understood it but they were comfortable
in the little this little that mentality
yanukovych upset all of that because
yanukovych said
i want the eastern ukraine leadership
wants to be part of of europe the
western ukraine leadership wants to be
part of europe so now we're truly united
as a country wanting to be part of
europe one of the reasons i got involved
with janet kowitz after i was convinced
he uh
would support ukraine coming to uh uh
into europe
it was the the my feeling that ukraine
was the equivalent of nixon going to
china only nixon could open up china
because he came from the anti-communist
right-wing part of the republican party
and so he brought republicans who would
have been the natural opposition
into the fold
same thing was true as far as i was
concerned in ukraine
eastern ukraine what needed
a leader from eastern ukraine that could
help them accept becoming part of europe
uh minimizing the the the conflicts that
could exist
when eushanka when the orange revolution
happened in 2004 i wasn't involved i got
involved you know after that
and i got involved frankly because
there's a little bit of what i was
talking about earlier eushanka who was
the western candidate and who won
was
renationalizing companies of eastern
ukrainian businessmen and then selling
them below bargain prices to his
oligarchs so the transition was
happening and an oligarch
who you know had a uh a a steel company
uh
was hired that had hired aiken gov a
democratic firm and they asked me to
help him as well
and that's how i got involved in ukraine
um
but
what happened in 2004 as a result of
this renationalization rep and then
privatization game that was going on
is
that the eastern european eastern
ukrainians decided it was time
that they really got actively involved
in becoming part of europe because
to be in the current environment that
ukraine had
it was not really getting the
protections
of
free market principles of of of
uh
some of the corruption issues uh and so
they got all in yeah witch convinced me
that he would be supportive of it and
and i got involved so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]